همم لنشرك اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي من عمان لواء فايز انت
تتابع معنا يعني حتى اللحظه بلوك تفيد بان
هذا الهجوم امم طائره مسيره مفخخه
لهذه الناقله المشغل لها رجل اعمال
اسرائيلي قباله السواحل العمانيه في حين
رويترز قالت بان الاسطول الامريكي الخامس
على علم بوقوع هذه الحادثه التي غالبا
وقعت يعني مساء همم مساء امس هارس ايضا
فقط يعني اشير لك انها الان تنقل ان هذه
الطائره المسيره يجري تشغيلها من شركه
تابعه لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي تؤكد ذلك انها
في متابعه لهذه الناقله كل هذه التفاصيل
يعني على يعني على قلتها حتى اللحظه ماذا
يوحي بالنسبه لطبيعه الهجوم والجهه
المنفذه على هذه همم الناقله التجاريه
يعني هذا الهجوم يوضع تحت اكثر من عنوان
لانه علينا ان ننتظر قليلا حتى يتم ااا
الحصول على معلومات دقيقه حول الجهه
الفعلي طبعا الان نحن نتحدث في دائره
الاحتمال من حيث القاء تبعيه ما حدث هل هي
يعني من هي الجهات التي سبق لها ان نفذت
هجمات سواء في بحر عمان في بحر العرب في
الخليج العربي هناك اكثر من حادثه واكثر
من همم سفينه سواء كانت ناقدا للنص او
غيرها تعرضت لها جماعه همم بعضها كان
ايرانيا والبعض الاخر كان حوثيا بمعنى اخر
ان ايران او احد ازرع ايران في المنطقه
وبالتالي تبقى هذه هي ال- ال-
المساحه التي يمكن
للمحلل ان يتحرك من خلالها بانها اما في
صوره مباشره او ان الحوثيين هم من استاذه
هذه العمليه لكن لماذا هناك تصعيد على
اكثر من مجال الان همم دعنا نربط همم
السيد اللواء الان اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
تنقل عن مسؤول امني اسرائيلي بارز اتهامه
ايران بالوقوف وراء هذا الهجوم على هذه
الناقله ناقله النفط
يعني انا انا ذكرت حتى قبل قبل هذا الخبر
العاجل قلت اما ايران او احدا يروح ايران
وفي كلتا الحالتين اما يرى ان تكون الفاعل
المباشر او تكون الفاعل غير المباشر اذا
الايرانيه تقف في خلفيه المشهد سواء كانت
هي منفذ مباشره بطائره انت حريري كمازي او
ال- ال- الحوثيين لماذا اقول الحوثيين
وضعهم من ضمن دائره الاتهام لانه سبق
للحوثيين ان نفذ وعمليات مماثله خلال
الاشهر والسنوات الماضيه وفي كلا الحالتين
تبقى هي خلفيه المشهد لكن السؤال لماذا
اذا عدنا وربنا خيوط هذه الاحداث علينا ان
نربطها مباشره بما يجري على الجغرافيا
السوريه وعلى الجغرافيا همم الايرانيه في
شمال غربي من كردستان وبالتالي لماذا لانه
هناك هجمات اسرائيليه متواصله شبه اسبوعيه
على اهداف ذات علاقه وارتباط مباشر بايران
وبيصال الاسلحه الى اذرعها في سوريا ويتم
همم مهاجمه هذه المطارات وخلال 48 ساعه
الماضيه كان هناك ضربه وخلال الاسبوع
الماضي كان اكثر من ضربه همم الان لماذا
شمال غرب ايران لانه بالامس كان هناك قصه
ايراني على مواقع تقع داخل
كردستان العراق لانه هناك اتهامات مباشره
ان المساجد الاسرائيلي موجود في المنطقه
وانه هو همم
تولى او يخطط او يساعد في اعمال الشغل
وبالامس قتل عقيد في الجيش اللي في الحرس
الثوري الايراني في احد البلدان الكرديه
في تلك المنطقه اذا يعني اقول المنطقه لا
استطيع القول انها على صفيحه ساخن ولكن
هناك اهداف متتاليه وبالتالي لكل حسب
قانون نيوتن الثالث
طبعا في سياق استعراض جميع المعطيات التي
تتوفر لدينا اولا باول رويترز عن مسؤول
عسكري بريس عفوا ان تقول ان الناقله
مستهدفه تحمل علم ليبيريا وتشغلها شركه
شحن مقرها في سنغافوره وطبعا مثل ما قلنا
هي همم ملك لرجل اعمال اسرائيلي وهذا ما
يفسر ان الاخبار تتوالى كذلك عن اذاعه
الجيش الاسرائيلي اا لواء فايز برايك كيف
سيكون لهذا الهجوم همم كيف ستكون تداعيات
هذا الهجوم برايك
كان يتم احتواء هذه الامور حتى لا يكون
هناك تصعيد لانه في النهايه امريكا هي
القوه الرئيسيه الفاعله والتي هي تستطيع
ضبط ايقاع هذا التصعيد من اي جانب
وبالتالي همم الاسطول الامريكي موجود امر
نفود الامريكي موجود تم الاعتداء على اكثر
من ناقله نقص سابقا تم الاعتداء على اكثر
من سفينه سابقه همم في حال المهاجمه اهداف
ايرانيه ايران تتمتع بالصبر الاستراتيجي
وتنفر عمليه الرد بعد في حال الاسرائيلي
تم استهداف اكثر من هدف اسرائيلي سواء في
البحر الاحمر في بحر العرب في في بحر عمان
ويكون الرد الاسرائيلي متاميا وليس ردا
عادي همم
قد يكون الرد في سوريا قد تستغربوا هذا
التحليل قد يكون الرد في سوريا قد يكون في
مطار دمشق قد يكون
قد يكون اذا دعيني اقول هذه لعبه تصعيد
وتصعيد مقبل ولكن كلا الجانبين لا يسعى
الى انفلات التصعيد من عقاله وانما هو كل
جانب يحاول ان يثبت للجانب الاخر انه قوه
فاعله قوه لديه القدره على العمل قدره
لديه القدره على الرد ولكن كلاهما في
النهايه يتوقف عن التصعيد عند خط معين ان
هل تتوقع